so what would happen if you ate celery
or drank celery juice every single day
now there's so many amazing foods that
create very cool effects on your body
and celery is one of them but
unfortunately there's not a lot of
emphasis on
using foods to handle body problems i
mean if you take a look at wikipedia for
example there's all this missing
information on the benefits of using
celery for various health conditions i
mean i'm going to put the research down
in the description below
but basically wikipedia basically says
it does nothing there's no research etc
etc
but the problem with wikipedia as a
source of
information is they're not really
focused on truthful information or
correct information they're focused more
on the majority opinion or who has the
loudest or
persistent voice but i've said this
before and i'll say it again what i have
found is you take what everyone agrees
on
absolutely as
truth
especially in the area of health
and you're going to find the truth is
more in the exact opposite direction but
let me get back to celery one stalk of
celery is only like 20 calories
it's 95 water so you really only have
five percent nutrients but that five
percent can create some
really cool effects
in fact before the 16th century
uh celery was used as a medicine not as
a food it was used in arabic countries
it was used in india
china
so celery goes way back there's this
very interesting compound
called 3n butyl phthalates and this
phytonutrient
relaxes smooth muscle okay
so it helps you lower your blood
pressure
it helps with asthma
and bronchitis
if the coronary artery is constricted it
can help to vasodilate that
and help get more oxygen and blood flow
to the heart muscle this compound also
helps any type of muscle spasm in the
body so if your muscles are very very
tight and spasmodic
cellular juice can help you so if you
compare that compound and its effect
with certain type of medications for
blood pressure
a lot of the blood pressure medications
make you end up feeling fatigued
lightheaded and even forgetful and that
has to do with what those medications do
to blood flow in your brain so it
basically can help you lower your blood
pressure without any side effects that's
cool and it also has an effect on
cortisol so if cortisol is lowered
you're going to feel calmer you're going
to have less anxiety
you're going to have better sleeping so
a good time to have celery is like right
after dinner and sometimes i replace
that
with my salad so sometimes i won't have
a salad i might have
four or five or six stalks of celery and
sometimes i'll add peanut butter
sometimes not but i'll make sure that
the peanut butter is organic because of
the pesticides and one point about
celery celery is unfortunately one of
those
vegetables that
comes with a lot of pesticides at least
15 different pesticides so always
consume organic celery
because you don't need all those
chemicals all right the next cool effect
that celery or celery juice has on your
body is in the kidney so celery or
celery juice can decrease your risk of
getting kidney stones it can help
dissolve kidney stones
it can also help dissolve
uric acid crystals as in gout
because it actually lowers uric acid so
in one study just using like 34
milligrams of celery seed extract two
times a day created a significant
improvement in pain it was like 68
less pain and celery seed extract also
works with
osteoarthritis and rheumatoid arthritis
so it creates a significant reduction in
pain and i think one reason it works in
gout is it's a very good alkalizer and
anytime you change the ph of your urine
to make it slightly more alkaline
the uric acid crystals
cannot be formed so these crystals
basically don't get formed and you don't
have gout pain celery is good to help
decrease the risk of stroke and also
recovery from a stroke probably because
it relaxes the smooth muscle and in your
arteries as well as increasing
circulation all right epigenin this is
another phytonutrient in celery
that has a very powerful effect on your
blood sugars so anytime you're going to
improve blood sugars you're going to
make insulin more sensitive you're going
to improve conditions like insulin
resistance and all the other effects
that happen when you improve that like
weight loss less fatty liver improved
heart
better energy in the list goes on and on
and on epigenin is a very powerful
anti-inflammatory so celery can help get
rid of inflammation and of course that's
going to help arthritis and rheumatoid
and things like that as well there's
also some research on that compound
increasing neurogenesis which is the
re-growing of nerve cells all right
moving right along i found another study
that drinking celery juice improves eye
strain okay so let's say you're in front
of the computer all the time and your
tired eyes celery juice can help as well
as improving blurred vision in another
study i found that
certain compounds in celery juice
have a similar effect to
milk thistle as liver protection and
that's pretty cool milk thistle has very
powerful hepatoprotective properties
it can protect the liver cells from
poisons toxins
medications well apparently celery has a
similar effect which is very cool also
celery can increase bile flow helping
you produce more bile celery juice is
very antibacterial it's antiviral and
like i said before it's alkalizing so if
you have too much acidity that could be
a problem so let's say for example
you're doing a prolonged fast
and you're on the ketogenic diet and you
have like massive ketones and your ph is
too much on the asset side
celery juice can help alkalize you now
i'm going to put a link down below to
help you identify if you're too alkaline
or too
acid celery juice also has
higher amounts of sodium but it's
nothing to worry about it's not that
significant and in addition to that you
have higher amounts of potassium so the
potassium and sodium ratios are really
good with celery juice and this is why
it's really good for
fluid retention edema
it's good to hydrate you it's good to
balance your fluids it's basically a
good electrolyte so in summary if you
were to start consuming celery or celery
juice on a regular basis
you're going to notice your kidneys are
going to be healthier you're going to
have less
gout uric acid and arthritis you're
going to sleep better you're going to
have less stress
and overall you're going to feel very
relaxed now one point i want to bring up
about celery juice when you're fasting
because the sugar content in celery
juice is so
minor so you're not going to have to
really worry about the celery juice
bumping you out of ketosis if you're
going to drink a small amount of it and
especially if you don't add things like
apple juice or carrot juice
or a little cellar juice either in the
morning or during the day i think it'd
be a really great thing to do for your
overall health even if you are doing
fasting now if you haven't seen my video
on consuming whole lemons i think that
would be a really good next video to
watch check it out i put it right here